Lemuel Gulliver was an English surgeon.
He went to sea when his business failed.
He was shipwrecked in Lilliput,...
...a land of tiny people where everything was much smaller.
At first he was a prisoner, then he became a hero and then was wanted for treason.
He escaped to the neighboring Blefuscu, where he repaired a boat and set sail for England.
After staying in England with his family for two months,...
...Gulliver undertook his next voyage.
It took him to a land of giants called Brobdingnag.
There he was captured by a farmer and became his pet.
The farmer sold Gulliver to the queen.
He eventually escaped from the giants when an eagle carried him away and dropped him in the sea.
Next, Gulliver set sail again.
After an attack by pirates, he ended up in Laputa, a floating island.
The people there were very smart but out of touch with reality.
His fourth and last journey took him to an unknown land.
It was populated by Houyhnhnms which were rational thinking horses.
Also, there were Yahoos, humanlike creatures who served the Houyhnhnms.
He wanted to stay with the Houyhnhnms.
But his bare body revealed to the horses that he was very much like a Yahoo.
Consequently, he was banished and returned home to England.